as soon as the bomb went off inside the
arena
a group of british transport police
officers ran to help
evacuating the station immediately it's
definitely a bomb
outside it was chaos it was ariana
grande's concert
and eight-year-old safie russos loved
her she was just
five meters from the explosion initially
safie's family were told that she died
quickly
but they wanted a second opinion and
they found
that safie survived for over an hour and
she asked
am i going to die i knew that i had to
read this report i knew that i had to
digest it but total shock
to what i was reading total opposite to
what i had in my head
all together um
i i feel gutted for something
that's how i feel i'm i'm
distraught anyway but i feel gutted for
that little girl
both safi and 28 year old john atkinson
might have survived their injuries the
next phase of the inquiry
is examining just how the emergency
services responded
and which mistakes were avoidable we are
not investigating
the emergency response on some
theoretical basis
scoring it against some assumed list of
points
instead we're considering how an
emergency response
may save lives and if so by what means
that is to be achieved
and whether it was in fact achieved on
the 22nd of may
2017. a pandemic means that even the
inquiry
chairman is following this from home the
ambulance service are too stretched to
be able to attend
but the resolve is there to carry on for
everyone who survived that night
and the 22 men women and children who
lost their lives
tom parmenter sky news